obviously it wasn't great feeling uh last game but
um H that was the question joall he's going to
shoot at the empty net oh just wide hit the side
of the net as he got Hood spot to try that in a
one goal game oh my goodness he got a lot on it
too I mean he elevates it over everyone rist the
delich he's going to go for it it's knocked down
in midair oh my gosh the entire building rose
up oh man I had the time I had the leverage
pass bounced across to paner but Z disrupted
that and they're going to call a penley here
I think he's got paner actually for the trip
on Zu oh they do p went down but he tripped
Zu first zo's going to theen he's not him he's
number 10 mine are probably tripping no no get
out of there he still won't go around someone
tells zo he's laughing coming to the P they
open the Penalty Box door he went to go in he
went to turn himself in SE back to G walking in
scores power play goal it's five nothing there's
luson in behind it front scores well there's one
38 seconds in hard back hit scores and it's
52 power play for Toronto it was a must score
k m fires scores must score get score Matthews
fir star it's a one goal game now a shot away
back and front scor are you watching this the
game is tied what a difference 19 minutes and
16 seconds can make hit Johnson scores it's
a game winner and the Columbus Blue Jacket
do Salvage a 65 win on a wild Thursday night
all right here's what what happened on the
tipped Puck out of play watch where it lands
it comes to a stop on top of the glass that's
actually one of our ice level mics and Mary our
audio engineer in the truck heard that loud and
clear you're never going to see that again all
right it's mascot madness here at the ring J give
me the play byplay Stinger with a break Stinger's
looking fast what is he going to do oh tops chees
no mercy no mercy on the children Stinger of Z
he's able to get it out as do throws the brakes
on behind his net and lost the puck oh my goodness
right through the crease and went cleano is still
on it then Myers goes crashing in terica slides at
Far Side Manson says thank you redirected in his
save by Lucen it flipped up not out fryo gloved it
down it's in his gear and he takes a hit this is
PETA finding the glass that's not out again givs
it up top one timer safe rebound oh it's wide in
the net a back hand stop and it gets through b
[Applause] score finally and the Avalanche had
spit and he turned it into the Buffalo Zone they
are rewarded turned over back to the net they
score and it's 4-2 gramlin PPS it and they score
and it's a one goal game four to three drops for
Eckland shoots they score and we're tied wow what
a comeback back here on the island 8 seconds to go
gr L Inman shoots and scores William Eckland wins
it in overtime what a comeback by the sharks so
the throw in on blar stop by lar the old scorpion
works that is called second effort period and a
great second effort they don't ask how oh that's
beautiful look at that Pock a deflected shot Shan
Flory rebound is still loose fur's down can't find
the puck maoy had it for a moment Middleton ties
him up it's still loose firstan scores what a
hockey game this is I mean Conor der no stick
the puck is laying there nobody can jump on they
can't clear it mckoy looks like he's getting it
out to the weak side doesn't fails that Puck's
just bobbling around everywhere before Maran jumps
on it and he's not going weak side there's still a
body over there it's post knock but Maran says no
I'm doing this myself he goes up over a sprawling
flurry to tie it they're unable to beat demo so
far butski gave it away for a goal my goodness Bo
you don't see that very often given the puck away
for a wide open goal we did get a chance to see
monmo briefly Kaden Primo doing his postgame media
availability and we see monbo Pop Up enjoying some
chicken wings yes when you get the night off you
can enjoy chick wings and going to clip his left
heel right there you can see the skate come skate
blade come off of the skate they survived some
significant pressure there it stays a 1-1 game
Winnipeg aead in [Music] shots R sure who he
was looking for on that one he's looking for a
whistle right now and Blackwood something's wrong
with a strap on his Pad right now that they need
a whistle and they tried to ice it for him and
now he's just going to shoot it out of that now
he's going to take a penalty unfortunately that
was just 4ly time know you're going to give Laur
bran I think he clearly knew what was going on as
the sharks tried to ice it and he came out of the
crease to play the puck so they couldn't get the
whistle welcome back to Montreal where it's the
have's 114th birthday and that calls for a cake
it was a bit Breezy out there you be struggling
with the lighter but thankfully it's metal Munday
who gave the mascot a flamethrower that is a good
question watch this he has an open net I don't
think he recognizes that Carter Hart's not in
the net he's looking to pass pass pass if he just
would have looked at the net he would have saw saw
that yeah look where his eyes are he doesn't even
know that Hart isn't in the cage what a break for
the Flyers j's got fres leg just and he dies away
from Joseph look at shiret he poked it away the
lineup with the return of Walker D here's poo with
a chance and that one off the goal post and that
was sto by lard I think we might get a horn here
in a second I think that puck one in the neck KY
back in the lineup puts it behind there we go and
it's going to be a one- nothing Minnesota lead as
Marcus Felino Johanson steals t spill ericon with
a shot he scores wolf was spun around by nzm cadri
his teammate and juwel ericon puts Minnesota Back
on Top by three nzm CER he loses an edge and goes
sliding right into Dustin wolf relays to Brock
Bess down the cloud houses to the ADV to get a
stick conu looking take advantage centering pass
M it was a five on three just for a moment one
minute to go in regulation oh open net there for
Kel and and he scores turned over to Jake gensel
and he didn't miss vasileski mishandles behind the
net the puck wet in his feet yensel just trying to
get it in front of the net that wasn't even a shot
on goal with the puck for Florida reinard shoots
and then from a tough angle the Panthers back
on top Puck bounced out in front onto the Stick
of barov and then Andre thinks that this Puck is
going to his right when it missed the net he had
no idea where it was and neither did the Dallas
defense and I think the dry Sidle and McDavid are
going to score enough goals we got another penalty
coming up here on Florida there's a call from The
Stance excellent posture there here's forsing with
a shot stick save made by arer bounces behind him
nearly cross the line now Andre takes a look but
that scramble boost he just kind of took his eye
off it and then soon whoa Carlson oet get a drive
and that knock the stick right out of the hands of
Jamie Ben it's his one shot attempt on the power
play he gets all of it and it just disintegrates
the Stick of Jamie Ben out of his hand sends it
deep wood keeps it moving not pass protus out in
front car's on net Wedgewood can't stop it score
a puck misplay by Scott Wedgwood behind the net he
fans on it his stick actually hits the end boards
as he's trying to backhand this behind the net M
staying with it hit SC no did it hit the cross
bar I thought kimby ronza knocked it top shelf
yeah hat in baby score that is top sh so who's
next off oh he's the slowest shootout performer
in the league here Wedgewood weights who Nets
off moves in misses he goes in and Meandering is
generous held in by St Sanderson has the lights di
now a Norris we got a little flicker of the lights
there no problem controlled by byro man a bomb and
his stick shatters sh score RJ col cleans up top
of your screen there's a deflection there's one
there's two and there's Ross Colton who catches
it he really studyed and want to play the way
he plays Leon tridle deflected off the Stick of
sight have it in and Edmonton catches a break for
a 3-1 lead across to De brinken one timer got to
spare in The Twig snaps in half and that allows
Candela a breakaway short handed give to the
back wow what a turn of events for the St Louis
Blues and this all starts right at the broken
stick oh boy look out collision at the line with
two teammates du for running right into K he ran
into a brick wall that'll make the video room
tomorrow of a few Chuckles all hand it off for
Kaden gry settles it down and he'll wait now
gry chased out by Crosby took it away dropped
the Backle Conor shot kicked out by Mono Crosby
scores Sydney Crosby created the whole play and
and he finishes it off with a goal too tough of
an angle Burrows gave it back they score Daniel
spra and now Detroit feeling it and they score
again can you imagine if you just stepped away
from the TV for a moment hey sharks are playing
well it's 3 nothing now it's 4 nothing slam dunk
goal we've got a goal tending change coming up
and now the sharks are getting a penalty yeah and
the sharks are down a man and they're down for
nothing it is a complete ship hurdle with ekli
hurdle shoots and scores and a breakaway zland in
alone scores two short-handed goals on the same
penalty kill I don't know what's going on he's got
it with st he scores three in a row and it's four
three unbelievable back to within one I don't
know what to say this is absolutely unreal two
onone Bailey stirred go they've come back from
4 nothing down in the same period it's tied and
Sturm has two in a row fabry Raymond score going
Lin granin loads up fires it off the boards they
score and it's tied again and now a foot race
and here's zland in alone on the Breakaway grin
scores they did it again the sharks with an
unbelievable comeback and then the overtime
winner here in Detroit make the most of it I
mean you don't know how long this hot streak
will go but there's no doubt that he's gotten the
attention of a lot of teams except they can't stop
that one right off the draw the shot off his
shoulder up over and into the net and Travis
conne has given the Flyers that elusive first go
well right obviously a disappointing start to this
game anything you're seeing out here that that uh
that you can build on we're on a way to losing 50
nothing right now I've never seen a team play
this brutal so at this point you know I don't
really I I'm lost for words to be quite honest old
tip in the check off has a lan turns it right over
oh hting stop Patrick Kane an awful turnover by
coov and he bails himself out TI B on your point
that's exactly part of the reason why we want to
see best off oh you so missplay that and it's in
two misplays one at each end Coach checkov able
to bail himself out and youo could not do the same
how much enjoyment do you get out of watching Mark
Andre flurry compete for you guys every night it's
unbelievable I mean it for him to do this at 50 is
is special and um you know he's he's awesome he's
great teammate great player and you see what he's
doing out there at uh at 50 thank you thater and
Sergey Roberto loo everybody Knuckles Landy came
out earlier and said wrong Jersey but we still
love Uncle EJ our producer of our broadcast it's
one of his family members I was able to get him a
ticket for the games sitting in behind Alexander
barov right there oh jacket Winger linesman into
the bench here wol getting some help to get up
here now I see a few Smiles appears to be right
yeah biggest hit of the period oh to the coyotes
catch up break there nothing in the tank for Kess
ring and durman take it away to the front they
score and it's Keller horrible turnover gives
it up to kerot and Clayton Keller that is a gift
and he will absolutely take it delay penalty up
coming here to Columbus Schmid makes his way
out and the crowd thinks it should be extra
New Jersey's goalie 2 minutes for playing the
puck over the center Red Line okay that's what
it called you're not allowed to play played over
the center Red Line Larson gets after it right in
to the blue they score as it trickles by cam tet
now if you ask lar he says you know what that's
what I try to do fake the shot and then let it
go between the legs of Cam telet down low get
in front bouncing around Crosby scores they got
a bit of a lucky bounce going off a skate but
because J Kel do that to the front of the net you
get the lucky bounce and Sid with those magical
hands Zak with a quick little back in just missp
side there's your glove stop for Jeremy Swingman
oh he's drilled right into the Blue's bench by
Jake neighbors what a hit by Neighbors on Peak
poster knock across poster knock he scored oh that
didn't go in oh it didn't that was post and post
oh my are they jumping here I thought that went
in pass it was just out of Zack heyman's reach
saw the Oilers were looking at there hman had
split the defense and butc David jams it in and
it's a tap in goal for Conor McDavid to make
it 3 nothing because you need permission from
the league to clear the bench in celebration of
something right the Leaf's team leaders asked the
league they said sure the problem was the team
leaders were Matthews Marner elander Riley all
the guys that on the ice the power nobody on the
bench knew that they were allowed to come off so
when they score look at Marner he started to wave
them out there come on neander come on we're I
swear the guys on the bench like are we allowed
to go what are we doing here is it a penalty oh
it's it's brilliant stuff the kind of stuff that
happens in a dress room s gets it back though two
on one down low s across thereo my goodness what
a glove stop by wo as tereno thought he was going
to open it up P across teraso oh Joseph wool
comes across and takes one away from Vladimir
teras Zeno back for stutler drink wine to BR
from sends it back in front oh what a stop by
wall he took that away point blank from teraso
again that's two tonight the terce SLE thought
were sure gold their carbon copy save I mean
they are identical Saves by wool on the same
guy skates into the Zone off the stick and tatto
was on his way to the bench heer's moving andat
with a diving play he lost the stick to stop
eers my oh my wow what a poke check things got
real interesting there they sure did rant starts
to leave the net oh no here comes nickers but rant
does a great job diving back gets a stick on it
Suzuki scores h on mono scores Coffield scores
rby twisting and turning scores The Bard hits the
post off fired stop by NAD delovic save mono miss
the net save mono miss the net Carlson's bomb is
stopped comes in shot score ell scores movich with
the stick cutter stop stopped by NAD delovic and
he missed the net NAD delovic stopped him save
mon gallager n delovic again with a stop and estos
up stop Anderson head fake n delovic gets a piece
scores and the are winners in
Montreal